a new PM arriving for her fast full day
of conference but what was meant to be a
Victory lap has instead morphed into a
fight for survival
hoping to turn the Troubles of the last
week around any
any fast and admission I do stand by the
package we announced and I stand by the
by the fact that we announced it quickly
because we had to act but I do accept we
should have laid the ground better I
have learned from that and I will make
sure that in future we do a better job
of laying the ground in the job less
than a month these first weeks of her
Premiership could not have been worse
but who to blame can I ask you promise
it did you discuss scrapping the top
rate with your whole cabinet
no
no we didn't it was a decision that um
the chancellor made
[Applause]
still remain in Resolute sticking to her
plan
's they both seem comfortable with but
these deeply uncomfortable times
a moment of unity a minute silence pay
and tribute to the queen this a party
pretending they're on the same page is
your party United William yeah it's
looking good very much so I think we're
all very United indeed
but within this conference and
throughout the party too deep division
this man a Tory big beast not convinced
the economic priorities are right I
think it would be wise for us to
recognize that they are neither the
right economic nor the right political
response to the situation that we face
at the moment I think that the 45 to 40
Pence tax cut is wrong and I think that
uh the therefore that yes it should go
yes
party chairman Jake Berry calling for
cohesion suggesting conservative MPS who
don't vote for the budget should lose
the whip what I would say to colleagues
is we have a new prime minister she has
a mandate both from colleagues on our
membership she absolutely has a plan for
this country that will create economic
growth the benefit of which will be felt
by every household in this country we
need to get on and Implement that plan
we need to unify behind that plan but
Unity is not the name of the game around
here former cabinet ministers are coming
out publicly to tell the prime minister
to change course whilst two senior
conservative MPS told me that colleagues
were actively looking at trying to
change party rules to house list trust
and replace her quickly without another
long drawn-out leadership race this is
not how she hopes it would be
[Applause]
protest on the inside and the outside
too the party uneasy and the polls
suggesting the public are far from sold
this a prime minister back into battle
Beth Rigby Sky News in Birmingham